[Musique]
ils inspirent les poètes faire réfléchir
les philosophes intrigué physicien le
temps joue un rôle central dans nos vies
et notre rapport au temps est intimement
liée à nos progrès technologiques comme
l'expliquent l'astronaute julie payette
[Musique]
quelle heure est il
combien de temps ça prend on se pose ce
type de question plusieurs fois par jour
depuis toujours on mesure le temps pour
organiser et synchroniser nos activités
quotidiennes
au début on a défini les choses assez
simplement mais à mesure que nos besoins
ont évolué on a divisé leur en unités de
plus en plus petit
la minute la seconde et même la
nanoseconde pour mesurer le passage du
temps on a d'abord utilisé le parcours
du soleil
vous le savez le jour et la nuit n'ont
pas la même durée en été les journées
sont plus longues
c'est aux égyptiens qu'on doit d'avoir
découpé les jours et les nuits en 12
heures chacun dans ce système leur
n'avait pas de durée fixe et en plus
elle changer au gré des saisons
mais pour l'époque ça suffisait ça
permettrait de savoir où on en était
dans la journée
c'est aussi dans l'antiquité qu'on a
divisé leur en minute et en seconde mais
pas en 12 en 60
pourquoi parce que les nombres 12 et 60
était très populaire ce sont les
champions de la division facile
[Musique]
comptez pardoux c'était très pratique
pour le commerce par exemple si on prend
une douzaine 2 on peut facilement la
diviser en deux trois quatre essais et
on obtient toujours de nombres entiers
pas besoin de fractions et le nombre 60
est encore plus du visible ça simplifie
le calcul mental
ce qui est fort utile pour la géométrie
l'avantagent ou l'astronome
éventuellement on a donné alors une
durée fixe mais pour ce qui est des
minutes et des secondes on ne s'en est
pas vraiment servi avant deux
millénaires en fait c'est avec l'essor
de la navigation et des grandes flottes
marchandes que le besoin de calculer
précisément les minutes est devenu
impératif de plus longtemps les marais
s'orienter grâce aux astres en mesurant
la position des étoiles avec un sextant
il pouvait déduire leurs coordonnées
grâce à des tables de conversion
la difficulté pour les navigateurs c'est
que la terre tourne il faut donc savoir
exactement combien de temps s'est écoulé
pour suivre le déplacement du bateau
quelques minutes d'erreurs et on peut
rater la cible d'une centaine de
kilomètres en mesurant le temps de façon
de plus en plus précises on a découvert
que la vitesse de rotation de la terre
fluctue et donc que la durée des
journées n'est pas toujours exactement
la même au fond tous les facteurs qui
influencent la distribution de la masse
sur terre ont un effet sur sa vitesse de
rotation
on pense ici au mari à la quantité de
glace aux pôles aux courants marins et
même au comportement du noyau terrestre
résultat les journées s'allongent de 2
millisecondes partiel qui pour vous et
moi
l'effet est imperceptible mais pour les
satellites et les réseaux informatiques
il faut absolument tenir compte les
processeurs modernes font des milliards
d'opérations à la seconde pour que des
ordinateurs puissent se parler il faut
les synchroniser ça prend donc des
horloges précise ou milliardièmes de
seconde et même davantage
impossible alors de se fier aux
mouvements des astres
depuis 1967 ce sont des horloges
atomiques qui sont les gardiennes du
temps on y mesure les changements d'état
dans des atomes de césium pour calculer
la durée d'une seconde de manière
extrêmement précise quand il y a trop
d'écart entre le temps atomique et le
temps astronomiques
on ajoute ceux qu'on appelle une seconde
intercalaires d'ailleurs il y en a une
le 31 décembre dernier dans le fuseau
horaire de greenwich
on a ajouté une seconde amie a fait le
vrai compte à rebours aurait dit on est
5 4 3 2 1 1
bonne année
ah le temps ça fait des millénaires
qu'on essaie de le comprendre de le
définir et de le contrôler et même si
aujourd'hui on arrive à le mesurer avec
une précision inouïe
le temps continue de nous filer entre
les doigts on lui court après on en perd
et plus souvent qu'autrement on en
manque justement il faut que viennent
ici julie payne à la prochaine
[Musique]